a couple of weeks ago president trump
announced that one
middle eastern nation would be making
peace with israel
we always hear this term peace in the
middle east as though it's something
completely unthinkable something that's
never going to happen
and president trump brings us that one
country right so what do people say oh
it's not a big deal
it's just the united arab emirates it's
not who cares you know they're pretty
pro-western
then he announces that there will be a
peace deal between israel and
a second middle eastern nation bahrain
that happened yesterday across the
street at the white house
oh well that's come on it's not that big
a deal and then
in a typical trumpian 11th hour surprise
he says oh by the way
we're looking at peace deals with oh
just about
nine different nations possibly
including saudi arabia
here's the president announcing the big
news
i do things differently if you if you
listen to the three
world leaders today and these are highly
respected
leaders and countries uae
is a uh is a tremendously respected
warrior i mean they're warriors they're
a very strong
respected country if you listen to what
they said
nobody thought of the plan that i
thought of and it's going around the
back door i call it going around the
smart door and coming in a different way
and we have many other countries going
to be joining us and they're going to be
joining us soon
we'll have i can i mean i think seven or
eight or nine we're gonna have a lot of
other countries joining us
including the big ones we already have
the big one but including the big ones
and this is not something that the
people that you mentioned would be able
to be
doing and it's not something that my
critics thought was possible
and now they say wow that was a good
idea i will say
it's gotten rave reviews even from the
new york times and tom friedman and a
lot of people
that don't like donald trump too much
why do we care about peace in the middle
east because we thought it was
impossible and yet
this guy this billionaire reality tv
show host
seems to be on the roads and already
making steps
toward that goal what does he say he
says going in
around the smart door all the smart
people all the geniuses
they couldn't work it out the region
just got worse and worse and worse and
then this guy donald trump they all said
was a buffoon
turns out he's the one to actually do it
how is this possible because
god uses the foolish things of this
world to shame the wise
he uses the weak things to shame the
strong the despised and low things the
things
that are not to shame the things that
are
big big lesson in here for politics i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday actually it's
right right on this topic
this is from g daddy who said yeah we'll
have peace in the middle east
has been a description of the impossible
or pipe dream task
looks like we'll have to change that now
to yeah we'll have a peaceful protest in
a democrat city
yeah because the the peace in the middle
east is probably going to happen
peaceful protest in a democrat city that
my friends
is a true true pipe dream
why is this all happening in the middle
east well
you know as we're talking about god
using the foolish things to shame the
strong i have noticed god has had an
interest in the middle east since
you know uh the dawn of time so you're
looking at a place that has been so rife
with with political chaos
just about forever and uh certainly in
recent years
and yet that's a topic that the
president goes after i guess every
president has tried to establish some
kind of peace in the middle east
didn't work out particularly well for
the last few guys who tried it barack
obama
george bush bill clinton bill clinton
probably did better than the other two
trump doing better than all of them
how is this possible because we're told
that trump is an idiot and all the smart
people don't like him because all the
smart people know so much better
this is true not just we'll move past
the middle east this is true
most clearly in the realm of science you
know trump and all the republicans
there's science deniers
do you know scientific american that
vaunted journal
scientific american is endorsing
a political candidate now a scientific
american is endorsing joe biden because
trump is so
anti-scientist the scientists with a
trademark over the
s the experts they hate trump so
scientific american for the first time
in its 175-year history
endorses a presidential candidate they
said they were compelled
to do so they said that president trump
quote has badly damaged
the u.s and his people because he
rejects evidence
and science he's attacked environmental
protections medical care researchers
and public science agencies that help
this country prepare for its greatest
challenges
he and his vice president flouted the
local mask
rules oh no he hasn't muzzled himself
all the time we told him to shut up but
he won't
he won't shut up he just keeps doing
things and succeeding
he's repeatedly lied to the public about
the deadly threat of the disease
he's denying reality and hobbling
all sorts of u.s science agencies
obviously
this has nothing to do with science as
we talked about earlier
on this show we're actually at the
beginning of this virus when everyone
said we need to listen to the public
health experts
you got to look at that phrase what is a
public health expert
a political scientist public refers to
politics
and then health expert i guess could
refer to a scientist
so you got science and you got politics
and this clearly this endorsement
is politics and it's divorced from
reality
isn't it you talk about donald trump
being divorced from reality let's not
forget that the so-called public health
experts have gotten
every single prediction about this virus
wrong
from the beginning all the public health
experts
and the democratic party right basically
part of the same institution
were the ones saying that we shouldn't
have a travel ban from china
who went along with the world health
organization which had been infiltrated
by china was a puppet
of the chinese regime they were they
just got everything
about the virus wrong and you know who
got a lot of it right as
as best you can during a pandemic donald
trump
that fool that idiot that unscientific
uh inexpert guy who just happens to be
more correct than all of the experts
greatest example of this this kind of
politicized science
comes from andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo the very unfortunate
governor
of new york the guy who handled the
virus worse than anybody he just tweeted
out yesterday quote science
knows that's the tweet because we've now
entered the
stoner freshman here's part of a
philosophy lecture phase of andrew
cuomo's governorship
son science knows
you know trouble with that tweet though
well there are a lot of problems with
that tweet
one is science cannot
know i mean the phrase itself
semantically doesn't make any sense
because what is science
science properly understood is knowledge
from
shire in in latin science now we use it
to refer to this
method of empirical study either way
knowledge cannot know people can know
things
andrew cuomo can't know very much at all
but people can know things but
knowledge cannot know knowledge cannot
do the process
of having knowledge because knowledge is
itself knowledge you know
you dig man consider
the kind of people who are talking about
science in this way in this in this
deified way they're talking about it
like science is god like science
is everything the the pro-science guy
andrew cuomo had the worst response to
the virus
the anti-science guy donald trump had a
much better response to the virus
even at the state level people were
always attacking ron desantis in florida
but a much more elderly population than
in new york
he's the anti-science republican he
handled the virus
much much better than the pro-science
guy
how does that happen what what about
what about good old science you know
some other things that science knows
science knows that
if a man wants to become a woman and
then injects himself with a lot of
hormones
that will make him happier that's what
we've been told by science right study
just came out
just not true just not true the american
journal of psychiatry issued
a major correction the other day
big retraction reanalysis demonstrates
that neither quote gender affirming
hormone treatment
nor gender affirming surgery this is
when a man basically
is mutilated to look more like a woman
has reduced the need for mental health
services
and then this was put out by public
discourse
is a gender anxious people deserve
better i kind of like that term
people who have anxiety about their sex
sounds kind of pc but it's a little more
accurate than than
some of the pc terms for transgenderism
or whatever it is
we were told by science remember settled
science that
uh people who are confused about their
their sex need to mutilate themselves
and we need to do this to children too
we need to inject them full of hormones
and castrate them and permanently change
their bodies
because it'll make them feel better
turns out no evidence of that
whatsoever as we have been saying from
the very beginning i actually did a
lecture tour that was in part about this
issue called
men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths we were attacked we
were called anti-science well
what does the science really say how
come all those egghead experts in lab
coats
are totally wrong and how come the mean
old orange man
who is a vulgarian and a reality tv star
how come he keeps getting things
so right there's a reason which we'll
get to in a second first i gotta thank
our friends over at keeps maybe it's
trump's hair
i don't know it might be he gets a lot
of power from his hair i like to think
that i get
some power from my hair i'm not exactly
a hulking adonis of a man
you know but when i was back in my
single days i would do well with the
ladies i think just because i have a
nice
poofy head of hair over here two out of
three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time that they're 35.
best way to fix that prevent it
prevention is the key and you've got to
start early
that is why you've got to try keeps
start
right now keeps offers generic versions
of the only fda approved hair loss
products
that are out there maybe you've tried
them before you've never tried them at
this price
the keeps treatments typically take
about four to six months
to start working that's just the way
that these
products work so you've got to get
started right away
these guys are the real deal if
you are ready to take action and prevent
hair loss right now go to keeps.com
knowles can ow l-e-s find out why a
hundred thousand men
trust keeps treatment start at just ten
dollars per month ten dollars per month
to keep your head of hair and continue
to woo the ladies
or just you know look good and feel good
keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash knowles head on over there
right now
then we can compare hair products and
styling tips and all that so it'll be
very fun it'll be very enjoyable
that's how the anti-science candidate
is comparing against all of those
vaunted experts so how's the pro
science candidate doing you know science
knows
science knowledge that that would be joe
biden right
well that scientific candidate doesn't
even seem to know who's at the top of
the presidential ticket
here is mr biden introducing
the ticket of biden harris nope uh he
couldn't quite remember that
harris biden administration is going to
relaunch that effort and keep pushing
further to make it easier for military
spouses and veterans
to find meaningful careers to ensure
teachers know how to support military
children in their classrooms
and to improve support for caregivers
and survivors
so much more than we do now people are
attacking
joe biden here because they're saying
gosh this guy forgot who's at the top of
the ticket who's at the bottom of the
ticket
he forgot that he's the one who's
supposed to be running for president not
kamala harris
and now this is plausible because he
also often forgets his name he referred
to the obiden administration
back under barack obama he has forgotten
all sorts of things i actually think
this is a moment of candor from joe
biden
which is that it's pretty clear from his
behavior
that if heaven forfeit he is elected
president
he won't be running the show he
obviously won't be running the show he
doesn't know
where he is he's been locked away in a
basement last night we had
essentially a presidential debate with
only one candidate
that was on abc with george
stephanopoulos we'll get to that in a
second because president trump did
very well there suffice it to say he did
very well but the format of it was
basically a presidential debate except
they wouldn't send joe biden because
obviously joe biden is going to be
devoured for lunch if he goes and does
anything like that
so yes it'll i don't know that it'll be
harris running the country probably what
it will be is the liberal establishment
which is why
these so-called scientists these fake
scientists like people at scientific
american and all the egghead experts
interested in public health are not
interested in health in particular
they're not interested in medicine in
particular they're interested in
politics and they're interested in power
and if joe biden wins he will be the
empty suit
vessel of this liberal establishment
power in which all of these egghead
experts
think that they can control our lives
that has been the explicit goal
of the progressive project going back at
least 100 years at least
to woodrow wilson and really before that
that you have
a science of administration a science of
history a science of politics
that takes choice away from we the
people takes choice away from our
constitutional system
gives it to these unaccountable
technocrats who are going to make all of
our decisions for us and who is the
vessel of that
this empty suit joe biden joe biden
getting off an airplane
ostensibly to do a campaign event gets
off the plane and he does that kind of
typical politician thing
he waves at all the people trouble was
he was waving at no one because nobody
was around his plane
he's stepping off the jet
there's maybe two bodyguards
and then he's he's waving at pretend
crowds of people
[Music]
he then turns so he's got these to his
right he's got
two presumably secret service agents
and he starts waving not at them but at
imaginary crowds of people behind them
and then
on the other side of joe biden he hears
a reporter say mr vice president by the
way joe biden's not the vice president
he should not be referred to as mr vice
president but then he turns around
and and you know obviously doesn't
answer their questions because he
doesn't answer any of the press's
questions now they still love him for it
but this was this was not just some
mistake that
he thought the secret service agent was
somewhere else he was
pretending just like he's pretending to
be at the top of his ticket
except when he forgets and he puts
kamala harris up there
then the greatest moment for this
pro-science genius canada this brilliant
candidate who in 50 years in government
never accomplished to never accomplish
very much of anything maybe one or two
halfway decent bills
that he's now disavowing 50 years in
government all this expert
doesn't give us very much actually
brings us to the situation that
president trump had to come in
and correct but there was one wonderful
moment when he pandered to hispanics in
a way
that would make robert francis beto
o'rourke blush
with embarrassment we'll get to that in
one second first got to thank our
friends over at readywise
now is a good time to prepare my friends
things
are getting a little crazy out there and
you want to make sure that you're
prepared for your family
whether it's natural disaster we're
seeing that happen all over the west
coast right now
whether it's a man-made disaster we're
seeing that happen all around the
country right now
now is a better time than ever to be
prepared with long-term
nutritious food from our friends
emergency meals free dry freeze dried
fruits and vegetables for convenient on
the go nutrition and
if you're an outdoorsman which i very
rarely am but sometimes i am
you get new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
which i just tried out i tried some of
these activities out last week and it
was very fun so now
now i'm gonna have to use that as an
excuse to be able to get the adventure
meals as well
ready-wise meals are easy to prepare you
just add water they have a very long
shelf life
they taste great they're really really
high quality but most importantly they
give you peace of mind
and if you have not been convinced now
that you need to be prepared
i don't know what is going to convince
you this week my listeners can get free
shipping
at readywise.com when entering knowles
at checkout
or by calling 855-453-2945 be sure to
mention knowles
readywise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy there is
no risk in taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family prepared today
really really great company offering a
very important product right now
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com promo code
knowles to get free
shipping biden then shows up to a
campaign event this is for hispanic
heritage month
hispanic by the way is only a racial
designation that's about
40 or so years old it was invented by a
bunch of these political science types
and a quarter of hispanics in the united
states today
don't even identify with the label but
whatever he shows up to hispanic
heritage month that's you know this kind
of racial division
is part and parcel of the left-wing
project
and he decides that joe typically is
going to pander to the audience how is
he going to do it
by playing a song from his phone
popularized
by justin bieber i just have
one thing to say
[Music]
there he is there you go swaying side to
side
laughing
[Music]
i'll tell you what if i had the talent
of any one of these people i'd be
i'd be elected president by acclamation
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you
and uh hello and happy hispanic hispanic
heritage month
hello thank you if i had the talent of
that
noted hispanic justino bibero
oh man that'd be i'd be great because
i'm old pandaren joe and he you like him
right now
yes it's true the song has been done by
actual hispanic artists but can you
imagine
this level of pandering it's why i said
this about biden from the very beginning
it's not that biden is some
you know radical leftist it's not it's
not that he's conservative or moderate
either
it's not that joe biden is a vicious
liar it's not that joe biden tells the
truth
joe biden is a cynical pandering
politician all joe biden is
is a wink and a smile that's all he is
it's all he's ever been in politics
there's a there's actually a website
it's been up for over 10 years now i
think called
joebidensteath.com and it's illustrative
because
joe biden is just a sort of caricature
of a politician he wants to slap you on
the back and say oh hey you're great
buddy
so he just goes there goes okay all
right what what can i use to pander to
people i'll just play this
stupid song and i'll pretend to dance
around to it okay and then i'll say that
yeah these guys are so much more
talented than me ha ha give me your
votes it's joe biden
that is silly pandering
not very knowledgeable not very expert
not very
scientific but this is the establishment
that is controlling us and it's
controlling our institutions of highest
learning
particularly on this issue of racial
pandering you want to talk about
experts not knowing their own field
university of chicago a once
great university this was once a top
tier university in the united states
the english department at the university
of chicago
for this coming year is not going to be
accepting graduate students
unless these graduate students want to
focus on
black studies black studies is a fake
academic discipline
it is a merely part of an ideological
campaign called critical theory
it you don't learn anything really doing
it but it's a way to train for political
activism
and to destroy the very culture that
you're supposed to be studying in
english but
there's a broader point we won't we
don't need to get into critical theory
president trump has made some comments
on this and maybe we'll get into it a
little bit later
in the week or next week i just want to
focus on
the english department if you don't do
black studies you can't study english as
a graduate student at chicago
i don't know if you know very much about
the english language or the english
peoples
for the long history of the english
language the
vast majority of them statistically i
guess a hundred percent
you know obviously there are some
exceptions in the more modern era but
generally for the history of english
it's been
white people writing in english because
the english are white because the
english
language has typically been used by the
english
people and the english people are very
very white
so if you don't focus on black studies
say for instance you want to study
shakespeare or chaucer or milton
or dunn or wordsworth or shelly or keats
or beowulf or if you want to study
any beowulf is going really really far
back we don't even need to
let's just look even more recently up
until
this very modern era and up until black
studies became an academic
discipline a few decades ago
you can't read that that english
language anymore this this was a
something that began
actually at yale a few years ago when
yale decolonized the english department
you no longer had to
study shakespeare or chaucer to graduate
from yale summa [ __ ] laude
in english preposterous i bet you donald
trump who they always say is
inarticulate doesn't have a good
handling of the english language
i bet you donald trump could have told
you more about the english language than
the university of chicago
english department professors
because they've become absolutely mad
through
their abstract theories english as a
discipline they write
has a long history of providing
aesthetic rationalizations for
colonization
exploitation extraction and
anti-blackness
what does any of that jargon mean not
very much but these are the genius
people these are the people with phds
these are the experts and the scientists
but god uses the foolish things to
confound the wise i mentioned yesterday
on the show
that there's this funny thing in america
where all the very fancy experts with
the very fancy jackets and you know very
fancy degrees
they're always shocked to learn that
your average run-of-the-mill american
knows as much and usually more than they
do bill buckley famously said he'd
rather be governed by the first 2000
people in the phone book
than the faculty of harvard college me
too add chicago and yale to that list as
well
why is that because what
when people get a bunch of fancy degrees
and phd and all the letters after their
name they
seem very wise but very often they're
very very foolish and people who
seem as though they're foolish often are
much wiser
how is it well this this came to total
fruition
this theory came to fruition last night
in the trump town hall which we will
touch on briefly
first though i've got to thank our
friends over at lifelock the fbi's
cyber division is now warning that
students and families
will be increasingly vulnerable to cyber
attacks because
of the current online learning use of
teleconference applications
okay since the start of the pandemic we
actually have some numbers here there's
been a 300
increase in cyber crime activity
hackers are becoming more sophisticated
they're taking advantage of this this
always happens
did you really think you could take the
whole country put it all online which
already
has vulnerabilities and then not see an
increase in cyber crime no maybe you did
i mean not because you don't think about
these things you think oh they're not
going to come after my information they
do you've got to protect your identity
very important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft
are affecting our lives now no one can
prevent at all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can
find out if your information is lurking
out there among bad people on the dark
web get your free dark web scan right
now there's no reason not to do this
guys
lifelock dot com slash knowles know w l
e s i
rely on these guys i trust these guys
pick the plan that's right for you you
save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
knowles there is a free scan at
lifelock.com
knowles get 25 off promo code knowles do
it now i mean now
now is the time when we're all online so
much it's it's very important to nip
these things in the bud catch these sort
of things
early following in the vein of the
chicago english department
uh the markles you know meghan markle
and mr markle formerly known as prince
harry back when he was
a royal and back when he was a man have
inked this multi-million dollar deal
with netflix well now meghan markle
wants to do a movie about the life of
the founder of the blm
organization patrice calor she's that
woman who
who described herself on camera as a
trained marxist
who kind of outed the organization as a
marxist front organization
she's been an activist who's taken money
from george soros i know you're not
allowed to say that anymore
but you can trace the money it's pretty
simple that's what they want to make the
movie of
these people who are in the ruling class
i mean
you know she's a royal right or sort of
a royal actually in the ruling class
but blm and the people funding blm and
the scientific establishment and the
media and all the
liberal established ruling class is
pushing this kind of radicalism on you
that your average common fellow on the
street would look at and say
nah i i don't agree with the blm
organization i don't think we should
undermine the nuclear family
i don't think that we need to foster
an anti-cisgender network whatever kind
of crazy language they use
practically much wiser than this ruling
class
this ruling class by the way which has
now tied itself to netflix barack obama
tied himself to netflix
he's getting zillions of dollars from
this like meghan markle
and netflix is pushing pedophile happy
movies
pedophile pleasing movies like cuties we
talked about cuties
earlier in the week they're pushing this
this is their number one product right
now they're standing by it
it's a degenerate filthy movie that
obviously should not be there they never
have to answer for this sort of thing
your average person on the street has a
natural revulsion
to something like cuties what what the
great philosopher leon cass described as
the wisdom of repugnance
you just know on your gut level you
think this movie there's just something
wrong with it
even beyond cuties this blm organization
that calls itself marxist there's just
something wrong with it
wisdom of repugnance the old common
people seem to have that
the experts and the wise do not speaking
of cuties by the way the director of
cuties
maimuna do corey is defending cuties
at the toronto film festival and
it shows you it actually shows you
something on this point
that we're talking about the wise and
the foolish she says
she's defending the movie she says it's
bold it's feminist but it's so important
and necessary to create debate
and try to find solutions for me as an
artist it's a real issue
it's important to see someone like you
on the screen
and to grow up with a lot of
possibilities so of course diversity
inclusion
have to be the keys to progress in our
cinema now all of that's just
gobbledygook's stupid words
but she is getting to one of the real
defenses here of the movie
i think it's a preposterous defense but
it sounds plausible which is
there is a problem in fundamentalist
islam
of treating young girls poorly
and in a sense sort of sexualizing them
or or at least focusing you know
you've got general mutilation
other disturbing aspects of the
sexualization of young girls you have
that there
and then in decadent western france you
have
another type of disturbing sexualization
of young girls namely this whap culture
of everything is licentious and
pornographic and disgusting
and both have these pitfalls that's
that's the defensible
possible message of cuties right problem
with cuties is
in talking about these things it
actually
sexualizes the young girls right these
are 11 year old actresses
and they're putting them on screen and
having them do all these sexual things
that's why the movie is indefensible
well what this woman's saying is it's
very important to see someone just like
you on screen and it reminds me of a
conversation i had with jon voight you
know the great actor john voight
a man starred in many very important
films
midnight cowboy anaconda that sort of
thing i was sitting with jon voight and
senator cruz we were doing a show
part of the verdict show and
jon voight pointed out that the acting
has uh has gotten better over time and
this is true as you had the kind of
more left-wing acting theorists and
actors come up you had guys like brando
right who
just gave a more naturalistic kind of
acting
than the people who came before him some
of those movie stars that came before
him cary grant those types
they were really in these wonderful
movies but the acting became much more
naturalistic and the acting today is
very naturalistic and you have
these method actors who are you know
totally
changing their body chemistry all these
sorts of things for the role
and then it occurred to me i was talking
to another another guy not an actress
talking to
john mourinho a great political
philosopher and writer
and john marini pointed out the acting
has gotten so much better but the
stories have become
so much less real in the old days the
stories were so real and relatable to so
many people
and the acting was maybe a little bit
worse but now all we care about is the
acting we don't really care about the
stories
so all the old oscar movies people used
to relate to them now nobody who relates
to these oscar movies
was it moonlight was one of the stories
a few years ago all these
weird oscar movies that nobody actually
goes and sees
but the acting is so good it's because
we don't
we don't understand even what reality
means anymore
right we'll take the emotional reality
of these
kind of individual people and moments in
the acting but we've lost sight of the
bigger story
we've lost sight of like what this
actually means and so on any little tiny
say it's a statistic for covid
we can zoom in really close but we don't
see the bigger picture we don't see what
it means for society
we've had we've had pandemics before
we've had plagues before in the world
this is the first time we've shut down
the entire country the entire world
over something like this why because
we've lost sight of this bigger picture
and often it's the common people and the
foolish people and the rubes and the
idiots and the deplorables and the
irredeemables
who can see that kind of thing while the
experts cannot see that kind of thing
and that's what president trump did
yesterday in this town hall we will get
to that right now
but first i've got to thank you head on
over
to the daily wire daily wire right now
if you subscribe if you go to
dailywire.com knowles use
the code watch you will get 15 off also
while you're subscribing i encourage you
to do that you should go
on over if you're watching this on
youtube go to the michael knowles show
youtube channel ring the bell subscribe
we're gonna be putting the shows on the
show channels right now
i like it when ben gets some clicks on
the daily wire channel but really i
wanted to go to the michael
show a channel and and really the reason
we're doing this is it helps us get
around some of the big tech censorship
that you know
sometimes puts a damper on all the
things that we want to watch when
they're not
politically correct because we've got
people in lab coats who tell us what we
should know and what we shouldn't know
so head on over dailywire.com
knowles code watch get 15
off we will be right back with the
magnificently trumpy
town hall
welcome back to the wonderful trumpy
town hall he killed it that's the big
takeaway the big takeaway is president
trump goes in
to what was certain to be a hostile town
hall with george stephanopoulos
who is now a pretend reporter and anchor
and journalist for
abc but in reality he's clinton's
ex-hatchet man he was
bill clinton's communications director
in the white house
he's a democrat operative who now
because he has
democratic privilege and he's a member
of this ruling class we tolerate as a
journalist
so trump goes in he doesn't care he
knows that the audience is going to be
hand-picked and it's going gonna be
hostile
he knows it's on a hostile network he
knows it's with a hostile
interviewer or mod moderator quote
unquote and he knows that his opponent
his ostensible opponent joe biden isn't
even gonna show up because he's not
capable of doing something like this
so he goes into the lion's den maybe
some
some people thought he shouldn't do this
because it's so
stacked against him and what does he do
he kills it he knocks it out of the park
there are a few moments in particular
though that highlight
what happened here because sometimes
people think trump
is too rash he's too emotional he's too
this he's too that
he went into this thing prepared he went
in
measured he went in strong and he went
in likeable the key is
he tailored his responses to the medium
he didn't talk like he was on twitter he
didn't talk like he was on cable news he
didn't
he talked like he was on network news
which is a little
a little bit of a more mature audience
they like it to be a little more calm
and respectful
and he did that this guy understands the
medium
and he was asked a question about this
actually about all the tweets and
everything
he was asked a question from a guy about
why he's not presidential
why he's not always nice why he doesn't
have the kind of
pandering soft back slapping air of
someone like i don't know joe biden
trump's answer typified his presidency
so i'm fighting a battle
it's a big battlefield and i have a lot
of forces against me i have the media
which i call the fake news because a lot
of it is fake
and i mean a big pope as you understand
a lot of it is fake
i'm fighting a lot of forces sometimes
you don't have time to be
totally as you would say presidential
you have to get things done
i think i've done more than any other
president in the first
three and a half years when you look at
what we've done for tax cuts and
regulation cuts and
uh the vets all of the things that we've
done for the west we have we have a 91
approval factor now for the vets so we
rebuilt our military we created space
force i mean we did so many things uh
right to try which is so incredible and
so successful you know what right to try
is
we did more i really believe it more
than any other president in the first
three and a half years
that's a great answer it vindicates a
thesis that i have been pushing and
actually the ann coulter put
forward first now for years the typical
argument about trump is that people
voted for him because of his personality
in spite of his policies they just got a
kick out of how brash he was and he's
not politically correct
and so they'll vote for him even though
his policies are all kooky that was the
consensus conservative view but it was
bs i knew it was bs
in wrote this book called it had a funny
title it was called in trump we trust e
pluribus awesome
slightly silly title but the book itself
was very good and she said it's the
opposite
and i've been saying it's the opposite
from the beginning too which is people
voted for trump
in spite of his personality for his
policies because he was offering
genuinely different policies not just
from hillary clinton
though that was important too but even
from his fellow republicans
he was seeing something that even his
fellow republicans the vast majority of
them
couldn't see and that was his answer
here they said why weren't you
presidential he says look i'm me
okay maybe you like me maybe you get a
kick out of me especially if you're a
new yorker
like drew and i think like trump a
little bit more than some conservatives
because we're new yorkers so we
we understand the way he talks we have a
lot of family members who talk that way
but even if you don't let's say you
don't like the way he talks
look at what he's doing look at what i'm
doing look at the reality
yeah all these expert wise brilliant
people
they spin a good yarn man they talk so
good
oh their theories are so great except
they don't work in reality
to to help people to make our politics
better
to bring peace to the middle east to fix
some of our manufacturing problems to
fix our trade problems to fix our
economy to fix our country
they don't actually do those things and
my policies do
and all my dumb deplorable stupid
irredeemable policies turns out
they actually accomplish the things that
apparently we're all supposed to be
accomplishing
that's a great answer then getting back
to racial grievance
you see the difference between the real
and the imagined and the wise and the
foolish
why the reality here was central to this
town hall and several questions
there's a guy who gets up he referred to
himself as a pastor i don't know if he
was
if he was a pastor or not but he gets up
and he was immediately hostile to the
president
and he asked this question about the
ghettos he said you know you're talking
about how america
was is going to become great again well
america was never great
for black people living in the ghettos
trump's response tells you a lot
how you know mr president good uh you've
coined the phrase make america
great again right when has america been
great for african americans in the
ghetto of america
are you aware of how tone deaf that
comes off to african american community
well i can say this we have tremendous
african-american support
you've probably seen it in the polls
we're doing extremely well with the
african-american hispanic american at
levels that
you've rarely seen a republican have so
he just totally shuts down
the premise right he had he had two
false premises here this
this questioner the first one was that
trump coined the phrase make america
great again he didn't he took it from
ronald reagan
and ronald reagan may have taken it from
richard nixon and of course this phrase
make america great again
has a long history in america because in
this country we used to like our country
until not so long ago so he shuts that
down
and then he gets to i mean he sort of he
sort of goes along with he goes okay
i see where you're going but don't
forget people used to love this country
then he shuts down the premise that it's
tone deaf to black americans why because
trump is doing better among black
americans according to the polls
than other republican candidates have he
goes i don't
maybe it's maybe you're the one who's
tone deaf questioner
then this questioner pushes further
he pushes on this issue of the ghettos
and why you know
the idea that make america great again
is this new phrase that's just been
coined
is the opposite of reality we used to
like this country
and now because of things like critical
theory and
all this left-wing claptrap in academia
that all the wise people are pushing
now we hate our country but that's the
new thing america was never great is the
new
idea that's the new phrase and it's the
one that this guy's pushing he pushes it
further
i mean your statement is though make it
great again so historically
uh the african-american experience
especially in these out of these ghettos
that have been out of redline
uh historically these ghettos have
systemically been set up
the way that they have been the
conditions of the drugs the guns and
everything else
that actually created the symptoms for
what we see
uh that you profess to be just the
democratic cities themselves
uh these things have historically been
happening for african-americans in these
ghettos
and we have not been seeing a change
uh quite frankly under your
administration
everything here is so backwards and
wrong so let's try to parse it very
quickly first of all
what trump points out is you're talking
about all these cities all these cities
are run by democrats
all of them every single one so
don't take it up with me man i don't run
the cities i may i'm the president i run
the federal government
if you've got an issue with some slums
in the cities talk to the democrats
who've been there so he goes okay fine
democrats run them but these problems
have been on for a long time right the
democrats have been running them for a
long time but
believe it or not so yeah it's a
long-standing problem for that but then
it gets worse because there's this
philosophical base where he says look
there's drugs there's crime in these
neighborhoods
these are these are tough neighborhoods
and and those are creating the symptoms
that we're seeing
what what symptoms are you talking about
the symptoms you're seeing
of these bad neighborhoods are the drugs
and the crime
the drugs in the crime can't create the
the symptoms of the drugs in the crime
kind of like andrew cuomo's mistake here
that science can't know because
knowledge is
knowledge knowledge knowledge itself
cannot know so what is
causing these problems notice here
this guy never has any sense of
personal responsibility this guy never
has sensible even local responsibility
it's all orange man's fault that the
cities
the inner cities have been bad for a
long time in this country
well the cities have been bad they've
gotten worse they've gotten better
because of some policies because of some
cultures falling apart
yeah those are problems but no sense
this guy talking as though america is so
awful
this is a new idea among all
demographics including black people
including people who live in cities go
read booker washington's up from slavery
he was the
leading civil rights advocate of his
time that was a man who was deeply
grateful to america
loved this country wanted to make things
better
but had a base gratitude for his country
and didn't didn't whine complain about
all sorts of problems to people who
didn't create those problems at all and
actually trying to help fix those
problems
this guy saying of the black experience
in america has always been terrible
this is a guy who is speaking on
national television to the president of
the united states
this is a guy who is embodying privilege
and he says
oh it's all a terrible awful no-good
rotten country
there there's no fixing that disease i
mean that that requires proper education
meaning you've got to be
raised correctly you've got to know how
to behave yourself and that is not
how you behave yourself to the president
of the united states that's not how you
should think
he clearly was not well educated albeit
i'm sure
he's being vaunted as this brilliant man
speaking truth to power
then you had another woman you had a
woman
embodying the same sort of thing she was
even more rude to the president she was
even more expert she had a phd after all
and she said things that were even
stupider
hi um mr president i was born with a
disease called sarcoidosis
and from the day i was born i was
considered uninsurable
that disease started in my skin moved to
my eyes
into my optic nerves and when i went to
graduate school into my brain
when it hit my brain i was automatically
eligible
for disability for the rest of my life i
chose instead
to get a bachelor's degree a master's
degree a phd
and become a professor great it is great
except i still have
similar health care problems it costs me
with co-pays
i'm still paying almost seven thousand
dollars a year in addition to
the co-pay and should pre-existing
conditions which obamacare brought into
uh brought to fruition be removed
no without please stop and let me finish
my question sir
no he shouldn't have let this woman i
mean he was being very polite because
this was network tv and i don't know i
mean he was being more polite than i
probably would have
this woman is being extraordinarily rude
she's saying very dumb things
shows you the state of the american
university that this woman could have a
phd
yes and the pre-existing conditions that
barack obama brought to
fruition what does that mean she's just
saying words just ain't gobbledygook
and worse than that is her attitude this
attitude of pride yes it's very
impressive
that i have a phd if if these are the
wise people
if if all these eggheads who hate
america at
every university now every even at the
most elite universities they're probably
the worst
then a phd doesn't seem to be worth very
much does it
all of these degrees all these alphabet
letters so wise they are
doesn't doesn't seem to understand very
much she's so rude to this guy
clearly wasn't well educated because
like for instance in the italian
language
when you the word rude ill-behaved is
male ducato
badly educate the idea used to be at
least that education was not just
stuffing your head full of facts but
actually was how you
behave how you are raised how you
comport yourself how you exercise the
virtues
clearly a lot of people in this country
not very well educated and it's funny
because trump who has
brash behavior on occasion seems to be
exhibiting very good behavior very good
education then she finishes up her
silly point should that be removed
within a 36 to 72 hour period
without my medication i will be dead and
i want to know
what it is that you're going to do to
assure that people like me who work hard
we do everything we're supposed to do
can stay insured it's not my fault that
i was born with this disease
it's not my fault that i'm a black woman
and in the medical community
i'm minimized and not taken seriously
black women are minimized in the medical
community and in public like give me a
break
my goodness gracious the only the only
three words you're allowed to say today
in the university in corporate american
public life is black lives matter
all the big tech companies changing
their biography black lives matter you
marginalized what are you talking about
and did you see the problem in her logic
she said she was born with this disease
and you know if
if she goes three days without obamacare
she'll die
how did she live before obamacare
presumably the woman isn't uh 10 years
old
how did she live before obamacare fine
she said i accomplished all these things
i'm so great and wonderful and important
i got a phd
okay you did fine before obamacare and
wasn't obamacare supposed to fix all of
these problems once and for all
how come we still have so many health
care problems oh cause obamacare didn't
do that
and all these wise wonderful people now
blaming trump and through trump because
they're not really even talking about
trump
they're blaming america the best hit of
the night
was a woman uh who was who was crying
uh she came out and uh she talked about
how her mother just died from
coronavirus trump handled this question
very very well take a listen hi mr
president mr george
hi everyone um my name is floyd lucetta
sorry if i can oh my hold my tears what
you just did
i came on 2006 with my mom from
dominican republic
sorry
she's just there she's trying to gather
her take your thoughts
that's fine george has plenty of time i
hope right
absolutely thank you you see a real
human empathy here this woman's mother
just died from coronavirus she's
obviously very upset by it and trump is
very comforting actually terry just take
your time comforting in all the senses
of the word he's he's very nice to her
but he's also saying hey don't worry
you'll be strong don't worry i'm get to
give strength is to comfort right yeah
george has plenty of time it's okay so
she gathers herself
and she's a supporter of trump she says
her mother was a supporter and she's a
supporter then she asks a question about
how he's going to fix immigration
what would you do for our immigration
system what would you change
to make more people like me and like her
to become citizen in both
okay and there is the question right and
i was wondering why did they let this
woman through
who's so emotional so so sympathetic so
pro-trump why why would abc and
stephanopoulos allow this
nice question in i realized then it's
because her question
involves this tough issue which is she
says how are we i'm so sympathetic how
are we going to
get more and more immigrants into the
country and the trouble is that actually
across party lines
the majority of americans want to
dramatically reduce immigration not
because
anybody hates anybody not because
anyone's bigoted or prejudiced or
whatever word you want to use
but simply because we've taken in we've
taken way way more people than anywhere
else in the world
over the last 60 years it's been the
largest mass movement of humans in the
history of the world
and we're discouraging assimilation and
we're telling people to hate this awful
terrible country like
these uh these academics and these
experts have been saying now for a long
time
and so we just can't do it we can't take
all of those people in so puts trump in
a tough corner
because he's either got to go along and
reverse his immigration plan and harm
himself
with the public broadly and with his
base or he's got to
seem like he's being mean to this very
sympathetic woman who likes him what
does he do
he says we're gonna have a good
immigration plan and then he starts
talking about the specifics her her
mother giving this personal comfort
he did extraordinarily well here it was
one of the best performances i've seen
from him
i'm perfectly willing to call out things
when i think he does something that's
not
really smart or does not really help him
last night he really helped himself
one last thought to leave you on kanye
west
kanye west tweets out yesterday that
he's the new moses
kanye west said i need to see
everybody's contracts universal on sony
i'm not going to watch my people be
enslaved
i'm putting my life on the line for my
people the music industry in the nba are
modern-day slave ships
i'm the new moses he's catching a lot of
flack for saying this that kanye west is
moses
love that he's right he's right i said
this earlier when kanye was
saying he was going to run for president
i read his platform and i said look it's
obviously eccentric
and he's a performer and an entertainer
i said but at a base philosophical level
this guy gets politics better than 70
of even elected republicans and
certainly than the entire left
kanye west he's an idiot he's a fool
he's a rube he's a deplorable and an
irredeemable he didn't know anything
that guy knows more than a lot of people
what he's talking about here in this
media establishment and more broadly the
liberal establishment is a modern-day
slavery of the mind it is a slavery of
the mind that seeks
but to destroy our culture
vox.com the liberal outlet is now going
after beethoven trying to destroy
beethoven maybe we'll try to get to that
tomorrow
trying to destroy the whole culture that
is a mental slavery that is going to
tear people apart tear our culture apart
and it's being pushed at the highest
levels with the wise and the experts
and the one consolation we have i know i
say often on the show
that a conservative constellation is
that reality reasserts itself in the end
another one is providence providence the
way that
even bad things get turned for good in
this world
and they do it not because of any
cockamamie academic theory they do it
because
god says so darn it and
all those bitter clinging deplorable
irredeemable rube idiots
who believe in crazy concepts like god
you know
against the will of all of the the white
lab coats those people those
common foolish people often turn out to
be right even when it's kanye west
even when it's donald trump peace in the
middle east my goodness can you believe
it that's our show i'm michael knowles
it's the michael noel show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton